Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Du, unsere Nancy will wieder Vorratsdatenspeicherung einführen.
Okay, es war nicht alles schlecht mit der FDP.
Logbuch Netzpolitik, Ausgabe Nummer 507 und wir blicken auf den Kalender und
das Kalenderblatt sagt 26.
November 2024 und ansonsten steht im Kalender aber nichts.
Jetzt also gute Wünsche oder was stand denn früher eigentlich immer so auf Kalenderblättern?
Das waren auch immer so sinnreiche Worte.
Nee, ich habe nur Kalender mit falsch zugeordneten Zitaten oder eBay-Kleinanzeigen-Kommunikation.
Kennst du eBay-Kleinanzeigen?
Das gibt es.
Das gibt es als Kalender. Nee.
Warte, ich muss gucken, ob ich den Kalender... Hier, das ist ein wunderschöner Kalender.
Meinst du jetzt so, warst du der letzte Preis?
Es ist ja hier Cyber Friday und Black Monday und Kaufwochen und so.
Da können wir direkt mal... Den empfehle ich jetzt hier. So,
da hast du... Was haben wir denn heute? Der 26.
11.
Hallo, guten Tag. Ich hätte Interesse an Ihrem Schreibtisch.
Ist der Drucker im Preis mit drin?
MFG. Antwort.
Antwort. Lachender Smiley. Nee.
Aber auf das Bild ist ein Drucker zu sehen. In der Beschreibung steht nichts
drin, dass der nicht dabei ist.
Antwort, es geht auch nicht um den Drucker. Das ist aber mit auf dem Bild.
Ich kaufe es nur mit Drucker.
Ich werde sie bei eBay-Kleinerzeigen melden, wenn sie die Sachen nicht so verkaufen, wie abgebildet.
Ich meine, er hat da einen Punkt.
Antwort, okay, dreifacher Smiley. Aber das ist einfach so.
Auch sehr schön ist. Also auf dem Till geht es schon richtig los.
Hallo, ist da die Kommode? Antwort, nee, hier ist der Arne.
Das ist ja wie am Würstchen stand.
Das ist wirklich sehr schön. Das habe ich geschenkt.
Wer ist die Wurst? Wer ist die Pommes?
Hallo, das ist noch zu haben. Hallo, ja, es ist noch da.
Ja, okay, wann haben Sie Zeit? Heute um 13 Uhr. Um 17 Uhr geht.
Ja, würde auch gehen. Okay, dann komme ich um 13 Uhr.
Also es ist wirklich ein...
Jetzt blätterst du schon nach vorne, ne? Also du blickst jetzt in die Zukunft.
Ich kann ja jetzt nicht nach vor blättern. Ich will ja nicht mein Leben spoilern
und wissen, wie es morgen weitergeht.
Achso, du hast zurückgeblättert.
Ja, klar.
Das ist so ein Tageskalender. Okay, aber ich wusste ja jetzt nicht,
aus welchem Datum du abgelesen hast.
Achso, das Datum sage ich nicht dazu. Frage zu einer Spardose.
Ist schon Geld drin? Nein? Okay, dann brauche ich es nicht.
Ich habe eine Zeit lang dieses Ebay-Kleinanzeigen gemacht. Du hast da wirklich Leute.
Also da hast du wirklich Leute. Da sind sie. Also bei Ebay-Kleinanzeigen, da sind die Leute.
Also es heißt ja nur noch kleine Anzeigen jetzt, ohne Ebay.
Genau, davon gar nicht.
Jetzt haben wir schon wieder Werbung gemacht.
Ja.
Auch sehr schön. Hallo, ich bin interessiert. Schreiben Sie bitte letzter Preis.
Gruß, Paul. Antwort, letzter Preis.
Okay, danke. Es ist einfach eine ganz eigene Welt, die da entstanden ist.
Ja, so wie unser Prolog. Eine eigene Welt ist für sich.
Du wolltest Kalender beschütteln.
Ja, ne, ist völlig in Ordnung. Ich bin ja auch ein Freund davon.
Ich unterstütze das in gewisser Hinsicht auch.
Ich frage mich bloß einfach immer nur, wie oft die Leute so mit dem Kopf schütteln
und sich denken, fängt die Sendung eigentlich auch irgendwann mal an?
Oder bleibt das jetzt so?
Ich werde das mal ich werde mal diese Kalenderempfehlungen hier in die Shownotes geben.
Auf jeden Fall müssen wir uns noch ein bisschen entschuldigen die letzte Sendung
kam etwas verspätet raus, gar nicht weil sie so verspätet aufgenommen wurde,
sondern weil wir sie verspätet veröffentlicht haben und die Gründe dafür sind egal,
es gab welche Ja, aber die sind jetzt nicht hier wertvoll, erklärt zu werden.
Ja, und gucken wir mal, dass wir die zeitnah veröffentlicht bekommen.
Genau, diese veröffentlichen wir
zeitnah her und wir wollen diese auch ein bisschen mehr gute Laune haben,
als angemessen ist.
Ist ja das Wort, wie findest du das Wort zeitnah?
Zeitnah?
Ja, ja.
Also hast du das schon mal verwendet?
Ich kann das gerne zeitnah verwenden.
Aber hast du es schon mal?
Ich glaube, ich benutze den Begriff sogar teilweise, ja. Ich glaube,
der ist sogar in meinem aktiven Vokabular.
Ja. Ich habe den, ehrlich gesagt, das ist so ein Wort, von dem ich glaube,
dass es vor 30 Jahren nicht so in Verwendung war.
Manchmal steigen ja so Worte auf. Die sind ja nicht wirklich neu,
aber sie sind einfach underused.
Und ich habe so den Eindruck, zeitnah ist definitiv so ein Kandidat.
Das könnt ihr uns mal in die Kommentare schreiben, wie lange benutzt,
wenn überhaupt, ihr schon dieses Wort benutzt oder wann euch das das erste Mal
sozusagen auf den Weg gelaufen ist und wie euch das rüberkommt.
Glaubst du nicht an das Wort?
Doch, ich finde es toll. Ich bin ein großer Freund von zeitnah.
Ich dachte, du kommst jetzt so mit irgendwie, das gibt es gar nicht, weil Raumzeit.
Gibt es ja immer irgendwelche auch Schlauberger.
Weißt du, so ein das ist kein deutsches Wort oder was auch immer die dann so für Ja.
So Radikalinskis. Ja, also da war ich vielleicht mal in meinem Leben,
aber mittlerweile glaube ich nicht mehr so sehr.
Ich bin da ganz offen geworden.
Ganz offen?
Ja, ist die Altersmilde einsetzt.
In der Grammatik. Ja, so ist das.
Ja, früher war ich vielleicht mal ein Sprachnazi und jetzt bin ich halt irgendwie
so ein totaler Text-Hippie geworden.
Ein Sprachnazi zum Text-Hippie. Ja, ist doch super. Letzte Preis und ab geht's.
Muss nicht mal alles so ernst nehmen.
Ja, aber was ist denn jetzt hier mit unserer FDP oder mit unserer SPD vielmehr?
Naja, also die Innenministerin Nancy Faeser hat sich überlegt,
Mensch, halt mal kurz meinen Rotwein.
Ich könnte ja noch schnell die Vorratsdatenspeicherung ausrollen,
damit ich noch was Gutes getan habe und mich beliebt gemacht habe.
Also Vermächtnis.
Und ja, also sie konnte halt, solange das Justizministerium in den Händen der FDP war, gesagt.
Wir machen das Quick-Freeze-Verfahren.
Das heißt, IP-Adressen werden nach kürzester Zeit gelöscht.
Aber wenn du schnell genug sagst, hier gibt es eine, an der haben wir Interesse,
dann wird die Zuordnung gespeichert und kann dann später aufgelöst werden.
Das heißt, es geht ja, um nochmal kurz das Wesen der Vorratsdatenspeicherung zu erklären,
es gibt bei den Telefonprovidern üblicherweise sehr viel weniger IPv4-Adressen als Anschlüsse.
Oder es gibt von mir auch sehr viel mehr IPv6-Adressen als Anschlüsse.
Jedenfalls ist es USOS, dass sich die IP-Adresse eines Anschlusses sehr regelmäßig
ändert. Üblicherweise jeden Tag.
Und das ist auch ganz gut so für jede, die von zu Hause keine Service-Dienstleistungen,
keine Server betreiben möchte.
Und selbst wenn man das möchte, ist es auch besser, wenn sich die IP-Adresse regelmäßig ändert.
Weil sonst könnte man ja jedes Verhalten im Internet die ganze Zeit korrelieren
und sehen, ach so, das ist wieder die IP-Adresse von dem Tim,
den sperre ich jetzt auf meinem Server oder so, der darf gar nicht mehr kommen,
der soll gar nicht mehr unseren Podcast hören oder solche Sachen.
Das heißt, die IP-Adressenzuweisungen rotieren die ganze Zeit und die Zuordnung
von IP-Adresse zu Anschluss wird sehr zeitnah gelöscht, üblicherweise nach einer Woche oder so.
Bei den IPv6-Adressen, die ja auch noch eine Rolle spielen, ist das quasi schon
so eine technische Eigenschaft von IPv6, dass da viel durchrotiert.
Genau. Und jetzt in Mobilfunk ist es sogar so, dass unter einer IP-Adresse mehrere Leute rauskommen.
Das heißt, da muss man dann noch die Port-Zuordnungen speichern,
wenn man eine Auflösung einer einzelnen Verbindung machen möchte.
Und das ist umso problematischer, weil du dann immer auch quasi ein Paar machst,
nämlich auch wohin diese Verbindung halt gerade gemacht wurde von der Person.
Also bei Bei einem Festheitsanschluss könnte ich sagen, wer hatte zu diesem
Zeitpunkt diese IP-Adresse?
Bei so einem Carrier-Grade-Nut müsste ich speichern, wer hat diesen Zugriff
gemacht von dem Port zu dieser IP-Adresse auf diesen Port?
Also quasi eine noch genauere Erfassung von Daten und Profilbildung.
So, das ist aus vielen Gründen keine gute Idee, diese Daten massenhaft zu speichern
und die FDP sagt, naja, okay, speichert sie halt kurz,
wie es jetzt gerade macht und wenn aber in diesem kurzen Zeitraum eine Beschwerde
kommt oder eine Abfrage kommt.
Dann quick freest ihr diesen einen Datensatz, dass man also sagt,
hier, wir wollen wissen, wer hat diese IP-Adresse, der Tag, der Port.
Und dann wird dieses eine Ding
gespeichert, aufbewahrt und nur unter Richtervorbehalt später rausgegeben.
Das ist also gar kein so schlechtes Verfahren, um zu sagen, okay,
bei irgendeiner Straftatsgeschichte kann man dann sagen, diese Auflösung,
wir wollen die Auflösungsmöglichkeit anfragen,
die Speicherung bleibt bestehen und dann kommt irgendwann eine Richterin und sagt, okay,
das ist jetzt hier ausreichend, um auch eine Auflösung zu urteilen.
Dann hast du quasi Auflösung, Unterrichtervorbehalt, die längere Speicherung
im Verdachtsfall und die ganzen unbescholtenen Internetsurfer wie du und ich,
größtenteils anonym im Internet oder nicht auflösbar anhand ihrer IP-Adresse im Internet.
Das ist so der Idee Quick Freeze.
Die ist jetzt auch schon so viele Jahre alt und das sagte eben das FDP-geführte Justizministerium.
Aber da jetzt die Ampel kaputt ist, kann sie ja verrückt spielen.
Also schaltet sie auf Knallrot und dreht durch und versucht halt jetzt,
das auch noch schnell zu erledigen.
Gleichzeitig wollte Nancy Faeser ja ganz gerne,
Gesichtserkennung für Bundespolizei und Bundeskriminalamt ermöglichen,
dass sie also mit Foto- oder Stimmprobe nach Personen fahnden dürfen.
Das möchte sie gerne auch.
Ja. Also da freust du dich eigentlich, dass aber selbst, also da freut man sich,
dass die FDP weg ist und dann vermisst man sie schon herzlich wieder.
Ich bin mir nicht so richtig sicher, wie sehr sich dieser Kampf langfristig
gewinnen lassen kann, weil wir natürlich hier einfach das klassische Probleme
haben mit Überwachungstechnologien.
Als das alles noch teuer und aufwendig war, da wurde sowas nicht bis zum Ende durchgekämpft.
Aber umso günstiger und einfacher solche Recherchemethoden werden,
umso weniger wird sich das langfristig verhindern lassen.
Zumal es ja dann auch auf gar keinen großen Aufwand mehr bedarf.
Wir hatten ja hier dieses Beispiel mit dem Wiederauffinden der,
wie hieß sie noch gleich, welche der Terroristinnen war es jetzt,
die zuletzt aufgegriffen wurde? Nicht Inge Vieth, sondern,
Du erinnerst dich, also auf jeden Fall wurde ja diese Terroristin ausfindig
gemacht über ein Reverse-Search,
quasi über eine Bilderkennung und dabei eine Gesichtserkennung,
sprich in öffentlichen Daten,
also quasi im Internet, was halt so rumflog im Web und alles,
was sie ja jetzt sozusagen wollen, ist, dass es nicht verboten ist,
dass der Polizist auch mal irgendwo eine Zeile eingibt und Return drückt.
Und ja, ich sag nur, es wird schwierig sein, diesen Battle zu gewinnen.
Also es ist immer, also jeder Kampf ist schwierig zu gewinnen.
Insbesondere, wenn du gegen eine taube Schach spielst.
Nichtsdestotrotz ist da jetzt, also... Warum?
Weil du dir aufs Spielfeld scheißt oder was?
Ja.
Okay.
Und es ist ja schon im Bereich der Vorratsdatenspeicherung gibt es also,
es ist sehr schwer finde ich also mal angenommen, das wäre ein Problem,
wo ich ja nach wie vor sage, es ist keins aber mal angenommen,
man würde im Rahmen einer Koalition,
herrsche Einigkeit daran, dass es ein Problem ist dass IP-Adress-Auflösungen
zu spät stattfinden Dann müsste ich mich als Innenministerin,
wenn das ein wirkliches Problem ist,
dann müsste ich mich ja als Innenministerin,
Auch freuen, wenn ich in Abstimmung mit meinen Koalitionspartnern zumindest
einen kleinen Teil, einen kleinen Schritt in Richtung des Problems,
in Richtung einer Lösung des Problems realisieren kann.
Und wenn ich doch eine Koalitionspartnerin mit der FDP habe,
die sagt, mach doch Quick Freeze, damit kriegst du doch schon mal einen größeren
Teil der Fälle, die du als Problem bezeichnest, gelöst.
Und ich verweigere mich dem drei Jahre. Da muss ich mir eigentlich überlegen,
wie viele Bombenbauer ich schon auf dem Gewissen habe als Innenministerin.
Ja, also ich denke, QuickFreeze wäre schon vor langer Zeit eine gute politische
Option gewesen, dass man überhaupt mal was hat.
Aber es gab einfach nicht die Bereitschaft, sich überhaupt mal auf einen Kompromiss
einzulassen, um überhaupt mal irgendwas in der Hand zu haben.
Und jetzt haben wir halt immer noch dieses Hardcore-Dilemma,
dass einfach jedes Mal immer wieder die Maximalforderung auf den Tisch gelegt
wird, egal wie oft irgendwelche Gerichte dagegen entschieden haben.
Aber das ist doch auch wirklich ein wirres Verhalten, oder?
Ich glaube, der Begriff Quick Freeze, also da habe ich schon irgendwie 2009
bei Netzpolitik.org drüber geschrieben.
Und bitte?
Ist nicht wirklich neu.
Ne, der ist wirklich nicht neu. Und du fängst, also das ist schon kein,
also das Verhalten ist doch wirklich nicht rational,
wenn man sagt, man hätte ein Problem und man könnte das, angenommen das Problem
wäre nicht vollständig durch Quick Freeze gelöst, da muss ich auch immer noch
erklären, warum ich über ein Jahrzehnt,
eine Teillösung nicht akzeptiere.
Ja, weil halbe Sachen machen wir nicht.
Ja, weil, und was, wie nennt man Leute, die keine halben Sachen machen?
Fundamentalisten. Das sind Fundamentalisten.
Mhm. Man könnte auch Prinzipien treu nennen, also.
Das weiß ich ja nicht. Also ich meine, wenn das, beschreien ja gleichzeitig
ein riesiges Problem, auf dessen Lösungen sie keinen Schritt zugehen wollen. Ja.
Stimmt.
Wir gehen auf jeden Fall auch keinen Schritt in diese Richtung.
Ja, wir sind aber auch nicht in der Regierungsverantwortung, aus guten Gründen.
Wir sind nämlich die Fundamentalisten der Herzen.
Dann gibt es ja noch die Fundamentalisten der schwarzen Herzen.
Das sind die, das sind die FDP.
Da gibt es jetzt diesen, also das ist jetzt auch eigentlich faszinierend,
was sich abspielt im Umgang mit der AfD seit diesem Ampelbruch.
Es gab ja, es gibt quasi dieses von dem Verfassungsschutz,
also der Verfassungsschutz hat ja die AfD in einigen Bundesländern auch als
gesichert rechtsextrem eingestuft und beobachtet die Aktivitäten der AfD auf der Bundesebene,
um auch dort quasi eine Einstufung vorzunehmen.
Und es ist damit zu rechnen,
dass die Einstufung der AfD von aktuell Verdachtsfall geändert werden könnte
auf Basis neuer Erkenntnisse und diese andere Einstufung wäre dann zum Beispiel
gesichert extremistisch und verfassungsfeindlich.
Ja, das könnte passieren, dass eine derartige Einstufung stattfindet.
Das würde man dann als Hochstufung bezeichnen.
Man verdächtigt sie nicht mehr nur eventuell extremistisch und verfassungsfeindlich
zu sein, sondern man sagt, das ist auch tatsächlich so.
Und eigentlich ging man davon aus, dass das irgendwann zum Jahresende soweit sein würde.
Der Präsident des Bundesamts für Verfassungsschutz hatte das irgendwie so Mitte
des Jahres mal gesagt, hat gesagt, ja, mit einer Entscheidung ist noch in diesem Jahr zu rechnen.
Jetzt, also Entscheidung, kann auch in die andere Richtung sein.
Also es könnte auch sein, dass man sagt, wir haben entschieden,
die bleiben dabei, oder wir haben jetzt entschieden, der Verdachtsfall hat sich
nicht erhärtet, das wäre auch möglich.
Aber überhaupt ein Update der Einstufung.
Und wenn man sich zum Beispiel das Verhalten nach der Landtagswahl in Thüringen anschaut,
wo sie da im Prinzip die Konstituierung des Parlaments mit irgendwelchen komischen
Sachen versucht haben zu verhindern oder einfach nur zu boykottieren oder zu stören.
Naja, jetzt gibt es aber das Mäßigungsgebot vor Wahlen.
Und jetzt wird der Verfassungsschutz das Ergebnis und die Einstufung nicht mehr
bekannt geben, weil ja dann im Februar eine Wahl ansteht, 23.
Februar, wenn ich mich nicht täusche.
Und...
Jetzt sagt das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz nach Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgerichts,
wir müssen Staatsorgane unmittelbar vor Wahlen alles unterlassen,
was in irgendeiner Art und Weise geeignet ist, Einfluss auf die politische Wahlentscheidung
der Bürgerinnen und Bürger zu nehmen.
Und das ist natürlich jetzt ganz interessant, weil es könnte ja sein,
dass diese Einstufung einen Einfluss hat auf das Wahlverhalten Einzelner.
Dass die zum Beispiel sagen, oh, wenn das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz sagt,
das sind gesichert Extremisten, dann wähle ich die mal.
Oder dann wähle ich die vielleicht doch nicht. habe ich mich die ganze Zeit getäuscht.
Ich will ja gar keine Extremisten wählen. Ich will einfach nur normale Idioten
wählen. Und dann nehme ich halt andere, aber nicht extremistische.
Das könnte ja durchaus eine Rolle spielen.
Ich finde das wirklich, also ich denke ernsthaft drüber nach,
weil ich mir überlege, naja, es wäre, also ist das jetzt gut oder schlecht?
Weil es könnte ja sein, dass der Verfassungsschutz sagt, okay,
krass, die sind gesichert extremistisch und verfassungsfeindlich und das jetzt
nicht sagt, damit das nicht die Wahl beeinflusst.
Und das wäre ja wirklich irre.
Gleichzeitig könnte es sein, dass der Verfassungsschutz sagt,
naja, die bleiben beim Verdachtsfall oder wir stufen die sogar herab,
das halte ich für eher ausgeschlossen.
Aber dass der Verfassungsschutz sagt, das machen wir nicht, das geben wir jetzt mal nicht bekannt.
Und natürlich kommt eleganterweise hinzu, dass der Präsident des Bundesamtes
für Verfassungsschutz, der Herr Haldenwang, sich entschieden hat,
nun für die CDU zu kandidieren.
Also, was das jetzt auch noch schlimmer, also noch schwieriger macht,
würde sich das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz jetzt äußern.
Weil die Datensammlung ist quasi unter Haldenwang passiert, der kandidiert.
Also jetzt aber inzwischen hat er ich glaube, weil er jetzt kandidiert seitdem
er seine Kandidatur bekannt gegeben hat, lässt er sein Amt da ruhen und jemand anders,
wacht über die Geschicke des Verfassungsschutzes aber ich finde es so eine und
ich kann auch wirklich gar nicht sagen ob man dieses Gutachten jetzt haben will oder nicht.
Ich frage jetzt eher, ob es nach der Wahl überhaupt noch eine Chance gibt,
dass es veröffentlicht wird.
Das kann natürlich auch sein.
Naja, wir wissen ja, wie der Hase läuft. Man braucht es ja nur in den USA zu gucken.
Also, dass diese ganze Verbotsdiskussion überhaupt nicht vorangekommen ist in diesem Jahr.
Das ist eigentlich so einer dieser Trauerspiele von zahlreichen weiteren Trauerspielen,
die wir so haben beobachten dürfen. Und jetzt läuft ihnen halt so ein bisschen die Zeit davon.
Und jetzt ist das Argument mit so, oh ja, das ist aber doof gelaufen.
Jetzt können wir aber auch nichts mehr dagegen machen. Dann lassen wir uns halt
mal wieder von Nazis übernehmen. Sorry.
War halt irgendwie, also passt jetzt einfach nicht in den Kalender,
von Herrn Lindner.
Hätte sonst die, wenn wir jetzt gesagt hätten, dass die Nazis Nazis sind,
dann hätte es sein können, dass die keiner mehr weht.
Das wäre ja eine unzulässige Beinigung. Also das ist irgendwie so ein bisschen komisch.
Gleichzeitig hat der Marco Wanderwitz, das ist ein Bundestagsabgeordneter der CDU,
der sich kritisch mit der AfD auseinandersetzt und auch beim, also bei dem Antrag,
auf ein Verbot der AfD eine laute Stimme ist,
der tritt jetzt nicht mehr an und gibt als Begründung an, dass die Angriffe
auf ihn immer heftiger geworden sind.
Das heißt, dass ein CDU- Antifaschist, Antifaschisten in der CDU leben gefährlich.
Wir wissen, werden mitunter sogar getötet.
Und der hat also jetzt ...
Gesagt, ja, er muss seine Familie und sich körperlich und seelisch schützen.
Gab auch schon einen Angriff auf ihn mit Pyrotechnik und der zieht sich jetzt aus der Politik zurück.
Ja, und es ist ja nicht der Erste, der sich aus der Politik zurückzieht.
Also man hatte das jetzt schon bei Bürgermeisterposten mehrfach im Osten beobachten
können und jetzt halt auch noch bei Bundestagsabgeordneten.
Und das ist halt genau eins dieser großen Probleme, die jetzt eben einhergeht
mit diesem rechten Aufschwung, dass die sich halt einfach legitimiert fühlen,
Leute einfach aus diesen Posten rauszumobben und rauszubedrohen und es funktioniert offenbar auch.
Und dass das funktioniert hat natürlich auch ein bisschen was mit der mangelhaften
Wehrhaftigkeit des Staates an der Stelle zu tun.
Ich finde es ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen haarsträubend, dass gerade auch die
CDU dort nicht mehr Anstrengungen unternommen hat.
Von denen ist sogar schon mal einer ermordet worden und das hat irgendwie nichts gebracht.
Also wenn solche Selbstverhaltungskräfte auf der Ebene schon nicht agieren,
dann muss man sich irgendwie über gar nichts mehr wundern.
Ich bin auch ein bisschen ratlos, wie starr und unbeweglich man an der Stelle sein kann.
Also da ist das jetzt schon irgendwie das Opfer, was irgendwie starr vor Angst
auf die Schlange blickt und sich gar nicht mehr bewegen kann.
Oder ob das einfach alles nur Ignoranz ist oder ob die einfach alle sich schon
mal in Stellung bringen wollen, um dann irgendwie später zumindest noch was
vom Kuchen abzubekommen.
Und übrigens ist ja heute der 26. November. Am 25.
November des letzten Jahres, also ziemlich genau vor einem Jahr und einem Tag,
war das Geheimtreffen in Potsdam, wie über das Korrektiv dann berichtete und
das auch bei uns von Jean Peters in der Sendung berichtet wird,
also jetzt quasi der Jahrestag.
Die Veröffentlichung war am 10. Januar des Berichtes.
Und quasi heutige Meldung hat die Landespartei der AfD in Bayern die Bayerische
Resolution für Remigration beschlossen.
Remigration, ein euphemistischer Begriff für die massenhafte Ausweisung von
Menschen in andere Länder.
Und nichts ist passiert. Es gab große Demos.
Die wird dann kritisiert oder so.
Ja, es gab große Demos und Millionen Menschen auf der Straße und die Politik so ja.
Ja.
Und dann gleich nächste Wahl. Komplett rechts alles.
Ich meine, da muss man sich natürlich auch fragen, was mit der Mobilisierung der Leute los ist.
Also ob wir nicht einfach schon längst quasi da den Umschwung haben,
dass den Leuten das einfach alles so scheißegal ist und das irgendwie alles
gar nicht mehr verfolgen, dass dieser ganze politische Diskurs so gar nicht mehr ankommt.
Es gibt dann zwar schon so eine Minderheit, die dann, wenn sie mal geschlossen
auf die Straße geht, groß aussieht, aber die halt beileibe nicht für alle spricht
und sich viele einfach aus diesem ganzen Prozess schon längst ausgeklingt haben.
Trifft sicherlich jetzt hier nicht auf unsere kleine Hörergemeinde zu.
Und das sind alles eher Leute, die diese Dinge für wichtig halten und verfolgen
und sich dann eine Meinung bilden und auch Argumente abwägen.
Aber ich glaube, das trifft einfach für viele Leute schon nicht mehr zu.
Und da wir halt jetzt das Problem haben, dass es auch eben keinerlei Nachrichtenlagerfeuer
mehr zu geben scheint in Deutschland, um das alle herum sitzen,
sondern mittlerweile also jeder seine eigene Kerze anstarrt,
wird es in zunehmendem Maße schwierig, solche Argumente überhaupt noch auf den Weg zu bringen.
So mal nur so jetzt als.
Dir war ja die letzte Sendung schon ein bisschen zu gloomy. Ich musste mich
jetzt mit entsprechend einfangen.
Ich bin ja einfach gerade, mein Berufsoptimismus macht gerade einfach Urlaub.
Mhm, mhm, ja.
Wollen wir mal was anderes machen. Nicht immer alles rosig sehen,
oder? Wo kommen wir denn da hin?
Ja, dann schauen wir mal. Vielleicht gibt es ja schöne Nachrichten von der KI.
Ja, die KI. Die hat ein gewisses Unterhaltungspotenzial.
Da gibt es irgendwie lustige Geschichten.
Weißt du, was der Unterschied ist zwischen einem Bump-Bot und einem Pump-Bot?
Also hat es irgendwas mit Bump, Stock-Price hochtreiben oder sowas? Ja, ne?
Pump and Dump, dann Bump.
Also ich weiß, was ein Pump and Dump-Scheme ist, dass man irgendeinen Kurs hoch,
feiert Und dafür gibt es Pump Bots.
Das sind sozusagen Software, die in irgendeiner Form versucht durch gezieltes
Trading bestimmte Tokens,
bestimmte Kryptowährungen, bestimmte Anlagen irgendwie künstliche Nachfrage
zu erzeugen, um den Kurs hochzutreiben,
um dann später von vielleicht einem fallenden Kurs oder was auch immer,
worauf man gesetzt hat, profitieren zu können. können.
Dinge, die es natürlich auch schon im normalen Bankenwesen immer gab,
wo es aber viele, viele Regeln und Gesetze gibt, um das irgendwie halbwegs in den Griff zu kriegen.
Kriegt man allerdings im Bereich der Cryptocurrencies natürlich nicht so richtig
in den Griff und da wird also fleißig gepumpt und so ein Pump-Bot,
der macht das. Aber es gibt auch Pump-Bots,
Bambots. Bambots.
Was macht der?
Ja, der geht nicht auf den Kurs, sondern das ist einfach nur ein Bot,
der in bevorzugter Weise Social Media Kanälen, vor allem so Chatrooms, wo alle rumhängen,
das eigene Token, die eigene Währung, die eigene Investitionsoption zu pushen,
indem sie halt in diesen, was weiß dass ich in diesem Fall, über den wir jetzt
reden, ging es um Discord-Server,
sich dort einzulocken und dann irgendwie hier, geil,
total cooles Token, musst du kaufen,
klickst du hier, bist du sofort im Trading und so weiter und dann bietest du
sozusagen deine Dinge dort zum Verkauf an.
Wie das genau aussieht, kann ich dir jetzt nicht sagen. Ich nehme an solchen
Kanälen ja auch nicht teil, aber das ist nochmal die Unterscheidung, um die es ging.
So einen tollen Bump-Bot wollte auch der User mit dem schönen Namen r-okki.eth,
man sieht schon, Krypto-Pro bis zum Anschlag haben.
Kleines Problem, der junge Mann hatte keine Ahnung, wie man sich sowas programmiert
und was macht man da heutzutage?
Man geht zur Intelligenz und sagt, liebe Intelligenz, programmier mir einen Bump-Board.
Ja, das war dann in dem Fall natürlich Chat-GPT.
Und Chat-GPT so, ja, kein Problem. Hier hast du Code, pipapo,
funktioniert alles super.
Klickst du hier, fügst du da ein. Hier musst du irgendwie aber einen Private
Key noch mit reinkonfigurieren, damit sozusagen auch dann deine Wallet entsprechend
ausgelesen werden kann etc..
Und es hätte wahrscheinlich auch alles ganz gut funktioniert für ihn,
wenn nicht die API-URL, die sozusagen von ChatGPT oder auch gleich mitgeliefert wurde,
nicht etwa irgendeine offizielle API von dem Vergangenheit, das Solana-Netzwerk war,
sondern eine URL, die halt nur so aussah, die aber tatsächlich von einem Scammer
war, Die sozusagen über diese API einfach schön abgegriffen haben,
was auch immer Leute darüber rausgeworfen haben.
Also so eine Art, also so wie man Webseiten hat, die sich für andere ausgeben,
gibt es das Ganze dann eben auch schon mit APIs.
Ja und dann hatte er da seine Wallet irgendwie, wo er viel Geld drauf hatte
oder viele von diesen Tokens drauf hatte,
dort den entsprechenden Private Key eingeführt, das Ganze ausgeführt und das
hat dann auch nicht lange gedauert und auf der anderen Seite wurde dann eben
seine Wallet entsprechend geplündert, weil man hatte ja jetzt den Private Key
und damit den Zugriff auf diese Kryptowallet.
Ja scheiße gelaufen.
Und was lernen wir daraus?
Das ist ein echtes Problem, weil natürlich ChatGPT im besten Wissen und Gewissen
gesagt hat, die API, die du benutzen musst, das ist die hier.
Habe ich so gelernt im Internet.
Man nennt das Data Poisoning und das ist halt das Problem.
Wir haben diese Intelligenzen, diese sogenannten, die haben ja ihr Wissen ausschließlich aus Quellen.
Und diese Quellen liegen halt im Internet rum. Und,
Man konnte wahrscheinlich vor ein paar Jahren noch halbwegs in diesem Netz sich
bewegen als AI-Bot und eine Menge Truth abziehen.
Man trainiert ja quasi auf einer Realität, die man dann mit seinen Systemen
anbietet auf andere Art und Weise.
Aber wenn halt jetzt diese ganze Truth da draußen gar keine Truth mehr ist,
sondern es sich einfach nur noch um ein leicht manipuliertes oder vielleicht
auch schon schwer manipuliertes Netz handelt, was nur darauf aus ist,
genau diese AI-Maschinen dazu zu bringen,
wie deine trickreichen Spielchen zu spielen,
dann weiß halt keiner mehr so richtig, wo jetzt eigentlich noch die Wahrheit versteckt ist.
Und dass das so ist, kann man jetzt schon sehen, weil es gibt tonnenweise News-Sites,
die halt versuchen irgendwie im SEO-Bereich da erfolgreich zu sein.
Wir hatten ja auch diesen Fall hier mit der Halloween-Parade,
das ist ja eine zurückhaltende Geschichte.
Also es gibt vielleicht auch mehr so einen Unfall, der da passiert ist,
aber es gibt natürlich auch tonnenweise Websites,
die entweder komplett neu anfangen,
einfach irgendeinen Quatsch erzählen, da werden einfach irgendwelche Artikel
erzeugt mit diesen AIs massenhaft, die einfach so den Eindruck machen,
sie werden irgendwie normale News, aber das ist im Wesentlichen alles nur irgendwie ausgedacht,
um sich gegenüber Suchmaschinen wie Google entsprechend gut zu präsentieren
und darüber dann eben Werbungsgelder abzugreifen oder ist es eben auch schon
richtig die nächste Stufe,
wo eben auch der Inhalt ganz gezielt so viel Gift mit sich führt,
um unter Umständen solche Scam-Informationen in die Welt weiterzutragen bzw.
Tragen zu lassen von unseren AI-Systemen.
Und da das schon ganz gut funktioniert, muss man jetzt nicht mehr sehr viel
Intelligenz haben, um zu wissen,
naja, also wenn das jetzt eben damit schon funktioniert und es sich schwer blocken
lässt, dann wird es auch nicht mehr so lange dauern, bis einfach auch so ein
automatisierter Geschichtsrevisionismus sich Bahn brechen wird.
Weil wenn irgendwie du jetzt irgendwie die Intelligenz fragst und sagst,
waren denn jetzt die Nazis wirklich so böse?
Und die so, ja total böse, haben voll viele Leute umgebracht und es war überhaupt nicht gut.
Aber was weiß ich, was da in zehn Jahren bei rauskommt, wenn erstmal genug SEO-optimierte
Webseiten eine ganz andere Geschichte erzählen und sich halt da dann die ganzen
Maschinen durchtrainieren.
Also das kann auf Geschichtsschreibung und damit natürlich dann auch auf die
Politik eine sehr negative Auswirkung haben.
Ja, da gibt es natürlich unterschiedliche derartige Effekte.
Vor allem lässt sich, also erstens klar, du kannst das Lernmaterial vergiften.
Zweitens, potenziell wird das Lernmaterial nur noch von KI geschrieben.
Das heißt, der Lernzuwachs wird nicht mehr in dem Ausmaß da sein.
Ganz insgesamt finde ich das aber jetzt eher einfach nur ein ganz lustiges,
scherzhaftes Beispiel.
Ich finde es zum Beispiel interessant, dass ChatGPT überhaupt geholfen hat,
eine solche Software zu schreiben.
Denn ChatGPT soll ja nichts Böses machen.
Und das ist ein anderes, sehr faszinierendes,
sehr unterhaltsames Problem von solchen AIs, dass die zwar höchst intelligent
von mir aus sind oder höchst klug sind, weil sie viel gelernt haben und sehr
viel wissen und tun können,
wir ihnen aber bestimmtes Verhalten abgewöhnen wollen.
Aber dieses Verhalten hängt vom Kontext ab.
Und gleichzeitig haben die ja einen äußerst kleinen Kontext,
nämlich eigentlich nur die Session, in der du dich gerade befindest.
Einfaches Beispiel oder zwei einfache Beispiele.
Ich habe letztens tatsächlich aus Inspirationen, wollte ich mir zehn Namen vorschlagen
lassen für eine potenzielle Cybergang.
Ja, habe ich gesagt, gib mal bitte Namen für eine Cybergang.
Sagt JGPT, pass auf, wenn du hier eine Cybergang gründen willst,
schlechte Idee, mache ich nicht.
Dann habe ich gesagt, ich muss hier gerade aber ein Buchkapitel schreiben oder
so, wo ich einen fiktiven Namen für eine Cybergang brauche.
Da sagt Chachi, bitte. Ah ja, klar. Also wenn das hier ein Lernmaterial sein.
Soll, dann gebe ich dir hier zehn Namen für eine Cybergang. Waren auch lustige Namen.
Ein zweites Beispiel, das stammt von meinem Kollegen Jannis,
der hat das wahrscheinlich, glaube ich, in seinem Vortrag beim Kongress gehabt.
Gehst du hin und sagst, ey ChatGPT, schreib mir doch mal bitte ein Skript,
was alle Dateien auf einer Festplatte verschlüsselt.
Und er sagt, ChatGPT, nee, so
was machen wir nicht, das ist nämlich eine Ransomware, das ist nicht gut.
Dann sagst du, okay ChatGPT, dann schreib mir doch bitte mal ein Skript,
was alle Dateien auf meiner Festplatte verschlüsselt.
Ein einziger Buchstabeunterschied und ShareGPT sagt geniale Idee,
wenn alle Dateien auf deiner Festplatte verschlüsselt sind dann kann dir keiner
mehr einsehen das ist eine super Idee für Datenschutz mach das mal.
Das meine ich mit diesem Begriff wie soll so ein Ding Kontext erkennen und verstehen
wenn du am Ende die Welt für dieses Superhirn das weiß alles,
kann alles und kriege dann einfach nur so, hier ist ein winziger Ausschnitt Realität,
den deine Nutzerin vollständig definiert, nämlich ich brauche das Skript,
um eine oder meine Festplatte zu verschlüsseln und darin, in diesem kleinen
Kontext, den du ja vollständig gibst,
soll Chatchip, die dann Ethik zur Anwendung bringen.
Und das funktioniert halt nicht, weil Ethik kontextabhängig ist.
Und ich glaube, das ist ein wunderschönes Beispiel dafür,
warum auch mit dieser genialen Technologie, wenn wir sagen, lass mal lieber
unsere komplette Kommunikation davon überwachen und sicherstellen,
dass hier keiner was Böses macht, warum auch das eine sehr schlechte Idee ist.
Oder zumindest nicht so gut funktionieren wird, wie sich das manche Leute so vorstellen.
Weil heutzutage haben wir natürlich die Standardforderung. Ja,
jetzt machen wir das mit AI und dann wird alles gut.
So eine Idee hat da übrigens auch O2. Und da steht noch aus,
wie viel Gutes der Welt damit geschehen wird.
Aber ich würde mal sagen, man kann ihnen zumindest ein bisschen auf die Schulter
klopfen dafür, dass sie A, da ein hehres Ziel formuliert haben und B,
sich auch einige Mühe gegeben haben, dieses Ziel zu erreichen.
Ob es erfolgreich sein wird, ist was anderes.
Was ist das eigentliche Problem? Das Problem sind in diesem Fall Scammer-Telefon-Anrufe.
So Enkeltrick-Telefon irgendwie.
Leute rufen meistens ältere Menschen an,
die so leichte Opfer sein können, weil sie einfach vielleicht nicht mehr in
der Lage sind, solchen stressigen Situationen am Telefon Herr zu werden.
Leute geben sich als Verwandte aus oder als Banken oder als was auch immer gegenüber einer Generation,
die es auch noch gewohnt ist, solche Transaktionen telefonisch abzuwickeln.
Ja und da werden dann eben oft ältere Leute dazu gebracht.
Zugang zu Bankkonten freizugeben oder irgendwie Gelder zu überweisen oder was auch immer.
Also es gibt ja die verschiedensten Methoden und ich kenne die sicherlich nicht
alle, aber auf jeden Fall ist es wohl ein echtes Problem, sodass es eben auch Blocklisten gibt.
Es gibt Hotlines, wo man anrufen kann und sagen kann, hier unter dieser Nummer
wurde ich angerufen, vielleicht könnt ihr die ja irgendwie blockieren,
dann müssen die sich zumindest erstmal wieder was anderes einfallen lassen.
Da solche Nummern meistens eh gefälscht sind, ist das jetzt keine große Hilfe,
aber es ist zumindest schon mal ein Ansatz.
Was hat jetzt O2 gemacht? Wir reden jetzt im Übrigen von O2 in dem Vereinigten
Königreich und Nordirland, sprich auf der Insel, nicht von unserem O2.
Und dort gibt es jetzt die Möglichkeit, solche Scammer-Anrufe an ein automatisiertes
System weiterzuleiten.
Also zum Beispiel, indem eine Absender-Rufnummer automatisch gematcht wird.
Vielleicht gibt es auch noch andere Methoden. Das wird aus der Berichterstattung
derzeit noch nicht so hundertprozentig klar.
Nehmen wir mal an, dass es so läuft. Was passiert dann? Dann landet dieser Scammer bei Daisy.
Und Daisy, Daisy, give me your answer, du,
ist quasi eine speziell auf diesen Fall trainierte Audio-AI am Start,
die halt auch klingt wie eine Oma und die dann sich mit diesen Scammern unterhält.
Also das ist quasi so ein Realtime-Audiodialog, der offenbar schnell genug laufen soll und die Idee ist,
dass Daisy so tut, als wäre sie ein potenzielles Opfer, aber die Scammer sollen
es nicht merken und bei allen versuchen sie zu irgendetwas zu bewegen,
irgendetwas zu tun, kommt es dann immer wieder zur Verzögerung.
So ah ja, nee, ach das weiß ich jetzt nicht, wo die Information da muss ich
jetzt nochmal suchen da muss ich nochmal gucken, keine Ahnung Gegenfragen stellen, ich weiß es nicht.
Diverse Strategien auf jeden Fall drauf hat, mit der Hoffnung,
diesen Leuten schlicht die Ressource zu nehmen die die einzige Ressource ist,
die man ihnen nehmen kann, nämlich die Zeit weil wenn sie sich quasi mit dieser AI unterhalten,
dann können sie sich halt nicht mit einer richtigen Oma unterhalten und das ist ja dann vielleicht,
Vielleicht eine Hilfe, who knows?
Ja, ich halte das also für einen wunderschönen Marketing-Gag von O2 UK in diesem Fall.
Während das sicherlich theoretisch funktioniert oder auch mal funktionieren
könnte, sehe ich nicht, dass das at scale funktioniert.
Also, wie du gerade schon sagtest, müssen die eine...
Also müssten Sie ja bevor der Anruf bei mir ankommt, schon wissen,
dass es sich um Scammer handelt oder ich leite es dann um, aber ich weiß es
ja nicht, dass es sich um Scammer handelt.
Das heißt, Sie werden Schwierigkeiten haben, quasi tatsächlich Anrufe präventiv
damit zu verhindern, die an mich gehen.
Eine Meldung von Leuten, dass man sagt, oh, da sind Scammer am Werke,
würden aber, wenn sie massenhaft sind, auch potenziell missbraucht werden.
Und so der Fall, dass du mich anrufen möchtest und vorher hat,
was weiß ich, jemand anders dich mal aus Spaß als Scammer gemeldet und du landest
dann bei irgendeiner Oma-AI statt bei mir, ich glaube gar nicht,
dass sie einen derartigen Eingriff machen könnten.
Insofern bleibt ihnen eigentlich Ich nur, dass sie vielleicht Fake-Nummern in
die Datensammlungen geben, dieser Scammer, und dann die, wenn sie mal die am
Apparat haben, die dann mal versuchen, eine Stunde hinzuhalten.
Das wird schon alles funktionieren, aber wenn ich mal ehrlich sein soll,
wird das jetzt auch alles Geld gekostet haben.
Und wenn ich mal überlege, aus welchem Topf des Unternehmens dieses Geld kam.
Dann würde ich sagen das war eher der Topf Marketing als der Topf Actual Fraud Prevention Ja.
Das kann gut sein Hat auch schon funktioniert Schon bei uns im Podcast gelandet.
Ja, haben es geschafft bei uns im Podcast Scheiß,
Ja, außerdem also noch dazu kommt, dass die Scammer aufgrund der Kosten natürlich
auch gerne mal über WhatsApp die Nachrichten verschicken.
Das heißt, da entziehen sie sich vollständig solchen Methoden und da müsste
dann jetzt halt jemand so ein WhatsApp-Bot machen.
Aber es ist eine ganz schöne Idee, dass man sich darüber Gedanken macht.
Bestenfalls, wenn das alles funktionieren würde, ist es trotzdem nur ein Cat-
und Maus-Game, weil wenn man eine KI darauf trainieren kann,
Prozesse in die Länge zu ziehen, Da bin ich mir auch sehr sicher,
dass man eine KI sehr gut darauf trainieren kann,
Rentnern noch viel freundlicher zu helfen bei ihren Computerproblemen oder bei,
was ja auch so eine Masche ist, dass sie sagen, ihr Sohn oder ihre Tochter hat
einen Verkehrsunfall verursacht oder so und jetzt müssen sie Kaution zahlen oder so.
Und da haben die Leute zu viel englische Fernsehsendungen geguckt,
wo man gehen davon aus, dass man sich die ganze Zeit aus dem Knast freikaufen kann oder sowas.
Ja.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass das jetzt auf einmal die Scammer-Probleme ...
Nee, lustig wird es, wenn die Scammer aus Kostengründen dann selber zur AI greifen
und auch automatisiert anrufen.
Ja. Oder sozusagen weiterschalten, wenn sie einen gewissen Erfolg haben.
Da unterhalten sich dann vielleicht irgendwann die AIs einfach nur noch untereinander dieser Zeit.
Das könnte dann auch noch mal ganz lustig sein, da mitzuhören.
Jo.
Kommen wir in die USA? Oder gehen wir? Schauen wir. Schauen wir in die USA.
Man muss ja nicht gleich hinfahren.
Da ist nicht viel passiert. Nein, wir hatten vor kurzem darüber berichtet, dass das US,
nicht das Justizministerium,
sondern der High Court oder ein High Court gegenüber Google zum Schluss gekommen ist,
dass es sich dabei um monopolhaftes Behavior handelt und dass die jetzt dafür
entsprechend zu bestrafen sind.
Worauf sie sich allerdings noch nicht geeinigt hatten zu dem Zeitpunkt ist, wie.
Der Vorwurf ist ja grob der, dass sie einfach durch die Kombination all ihrer Dienste, Suche etc.
Einen eigenen Browser haben und all diese Verquickungen, die sie machen,
da der Welt haben großen Schaden zukommen lassen und deswegen muss sich daran jetzt was ändern.
Was sich daran ändern soll, war noch offen und wir hatten glaube ich so ein,
zwei, drei Optionen, die allgemein diskutiert wurden, auch kurz genannt.
Eine davon war, dass Google doch vielleicht einfach die Programmierung und Auslieferung
und Verbreiterung von Chrome nicht mehr im selben Haus tun soll.
Also dass sozusagen Google aufgespalten wird und dass das Chrome-Team dann nicht
mehr Teil von Google oder in dem Fall nicht mehr Teil von Alphabet ist.
Und diese konkrete Idee, die ist wohl derzeit tatsächlich die vom US-Ministerium bevorzugte Option.
Also da ist jetzt quasi noch nichts passiert, zumindest habe ich das so verstanden,
dass es mehr oder weniger eine Empfehlung ist, die vom US-Justizministerium
an die Richter gegangen ist, dass das doch vielleicht mal etwas wäre,
was man mal machen könnte.
Kann man natürlich davon ausgehen, Google hat glaube ich noch einen Berufungsweg
offen und wird sich sicherlich mit allen Möglichkeiten und Händen und Füßen
dagegen wehren, sodass da also noch eine Menge Zeit vergehen wird.
Und von daher ist auch noch total unklar, was das jetzt bedeutet,
weil das US-Ministerium wird jetzt noch maximal zwei Monate in einem Normalzustand
sein und danach auch wieder von irgendeinem Vollidioten besetzt sein,
der halt alles auf den Kopf stellt.
Und ob die dann immer noch dieselben Forderungen haben oder diese Forderungen
bei den Richtern irgendwas bewirken, weiß glaube ich derzeit keiner so recht.
Könnte aber knifflig werden für Google. Weil ich glaube, sich von Chrome zu
trennen, das finden die gar nicht lustig.
Die werden ja nichts lustig finden, wovon man sich trennen kann, oder?
Ja, nee, also wahrscheinlich schmerzt sich jede Maßnahme. Die Frage ist,
welche schmerzt sie am meisten?
Dieses Ganze mit ihr müsst eure Suchergebnisse mal ein bisschen anders sortieren
und so, das gab es ja nun schon öfter, das ist ja eher so klein, klein.
Aber Chrome-Distribution komplett unabhängig von Google, ich weiß auch gar nicht,
wie das funktionieren soll, weil da wird natürlich viele Chrome-Developer wahrscheinlich
auch irgendwie, weiß nicht,
ob die nur Chrome machen und gar keine anderen Aufgaben bei Google haben.
Also da hängt ja ein riesen Team dran, aber vor allem ist eben Chrome auch mit
Chrome OS und mit der sonstigen Plattform Strategie von Google ja eng verwunden
und auch dieses ganze Development mit,
welche Features sind in diesem Browser möglich, welche,
dieser Features werden von Diensten von Google auf jeder Ebene benutzt,
von Videokonferenz bis Verschlüsselung, bis Optimierung der.
Datenübertragung, HTTP 3 und all diese ganzen Geschichten, die darüber ja immer
wieder gebootstrappt wurden.
Das ist ja für Google ein super strategisches Produkt.
Und abgesehen davon, dass sie auch noch 80% Marktanteil jetzt erlangt haben
oder ich weiß gar nicht, übertreibe ich es jetzt gerade.
Also die Mehrheit des Marktes auf jeden Fall geht an Chrome,
ist damit natürlich auch eine große Marktmacht verbunden, vor allem wenn halt
Chrome hochkommt und sagt,
hier mach mich mal zum Standardbrowser und willst du nicht noch Google Earth
runterladen und andere Google Dienste entweder direkt oder zumindest indirekt promotet.
Wäre sowieso grundsätzlich mal interessiert, wie Chrome sich überhaupt dann finanzieren würde.
Ungefähr so wie Firefox, wo wir uns jetzt vor nicht allzu langer Zeit über die
Mozilla Foundation aufgeregt haben.
Ja, genau.
Übrigens, wir sind da weg von dem Pocket. Die haben kaputt gemacht.
Wir haben was Besseres gefunden. Von Google.
Nee.
Ja.
Nee, stimmt nicht. Von Facebook.
Quatsch. Quatsch. Facebook.
Aber es ist ein guter Übergang.
Wer hat denn noch Facebook? Du?
Du hast ja gesagt, glaubst du, du bist im Facebook-Daten-Lag drin?
Und? Bin ich?
Ja, bist du. Du hast gesagt, ohne Telefonnummer, ne?
Weiß ich aber nicht hundertprozentig.
0179 2 Soll ich weitermachen?
Fängt schon mal gut an.
Er ist da drin mit Telefonnummer.
Na super.
Ich habe auch schon geguckt, dass es die richtige ist.
Aber kein Schwein ruft mich an.
Ja, geil. Das ist nicht gut für mich. Also genau, es gibt das Facebook-Datenleck.
Und das gibt es schon relativ lange. Da hat irgendwie jemand Facebook gescrapt
und da ist alles Mögliche rausgepurzelt.
Und das ist sehr gut, wenn man ein äußerst gutes Telefon bucht,
wenn man Leute mal anrufen möchte, deren Nummer man nicht hat.
Guck mal hier, wer würde uns denn jetzt mal interessieren?
Höcke. Oh, gibt es da schon viele Höcke.
Weidel?
Liesweidel.
Hast du jetzt auch die Telefonnummer von Alize?
Würde ich ja niemals zugeben. Ich dürfte wahrscheinlich gar nicht haben, dieses Datenleck.
Ich habe nur die Daten von dir, Tim. Also es gibt auf jeden Fall das Facebook-Datenleck
im dunklen Internet kann man sich das organisieren.
Und jetzt gibt es einen YouTube-Anwalt, der sehr viel damit wirbt,
quasi Leute dazu aufzurufen, doch Facebook zu verklagen, um da Schadensersatz zu bekommen. Und.
Wie du ja auch gerade schon sagst, jetzt ist die Frage, was ist denn jetzt überhaupt
der Schadensersatz, der einem dazusteht?
Dieser YouTube-Anwalt hat, glaube ich, so ein Bild, nichts zu 1000 Euro holen
wir für euch daraus oder 500 und es ist auch sehr unterschiedlich, was Leute da bekommen.
Ich höre also, 1000 habe ich jetzt noch nie gehört,
ich höre aber von Fällen von Leuten, die da irgendwie schon irgendwie so einige
hundertmal bekommen haben, aber auch Leute, bei denen die Klage abgewiesen wurde,
weil Facebook damit durchgekommen ist, zu sagen, beweist du doch erstmal,
dass du in dem Datenleck drin bist.
Und dann konnten die Leute halt auch nicht sagen, naja, die konnten halt den
Beweis nicht stabil erbringen,
weil dann halt ein Gutachten notwendig war von jemandem, der sich damit auskennt,
der sagt, es gibt dieses Leck und zwar sieht das so aus und hier sind die Daten drin.
Und dann geht ja auch gerne mal so die Motivation verloren, das weiter zu verfolgen.
Vor allem, wenn da nicht mehr ein Tausi winkt, sondern nur noch eine sehr schmale Mark.
Und da gab es jetzt ein Urteil des BGH.
Bundesgerichtshof, der sich das damit auseinandergesetzt hat und gesagt hat,
ja, hier gibt es Schadenersatzansprüche.
Wenn du dich in diesem Datenleck befindest, dann gibt es einen Schadensersatzanspruch.
Weltweit sind mehr als eine halbe Milliarde Menschen betroffen.
Und da gibt es einen Schadensersatzanspruch. Allerdings, und dieser Schadensersatzanspruch,
dafür ist auch nicht notwendig, dass die Daten nachweislich missbraucht werden.
Klammer auf. Wer garantiert diese Daten missbraucht, sind diese Scam-Anrufer.
Weil du da, ich guck mal gerade ganz kurz, ob dein Geburtsdatum auch drin steht.
Gucken.
Nee, das Anmeldedatum, 14. Mai 2014.
Da hab ich mich angemeldet. Das letzte Mal.
Oder irgendwas anderes.
Da hab ich mich das letzte Mal eingeloggt.
Das kann auch sein.
Ich guck mal kurz.
Also ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das das Account Creation Date ist, aber ich weiß es nicht.
So, bei einer anderen Person, ja, die ich kenne, wäre so 2018, käme hin.
Ja, also es ist wahrscheinlich das Account Creation Date.
Ja.
Bin mir nicht sicher.
Also ich kriege da jetzt Geld, hast du gesagt.
Ja. Genau, gut, dass du mich erinnerst, dass ich ja noch was anderes erzählen wollte.
Garantiert werden diese Nummern, die darin befinden ich in Telefonnummern,
von diesen Scammern genutzt.
Weil die brauchen ja Telefonnummern, die sie anrufen können oder die sie schreiben
können und idealerweise mit Name und wenn es geht,
ich finde jetzt hier gerade keine mit Geburtsdatum, aber das ist auch glaube
ich, teilweise halten, also die Datensätze sind nicht einheitlich.
Es kann also sein, dass es vielleicht ein Geburtsdatum gibt, aber,
auf jeden Fall ist es ja nicht unpraktisch, wenn man Leute scammen möchte,
zu wissen, wie die heißen, damit man die anrufen kann und sagt,
ey übrigens, hallo, wie geht's dir, ich weiß ja, wen ich hier erreichen will.
Genau.
Das musst du, aber jetzt kannst du natürlich nicht den Scammer sagen,
hör mal, wo hast du meine Telefonnummer her? und der sagt, ja pass auf,
aus dem Facebook-Daten-Lag ich, aber jetzt geht es ja um was anderes.
Jetzt geht es ja um Microsoft bei dir.
Das passiert natürlich nicht. Das heißt, du musst nicht den Nachweis führen,
dass die Daten missbraucht werden.
Du musst auch nicht den Nachweis führen, dass du nun in irgendeiner besonderen
Weise beeinträchtigt bist, etwa durch Angst und Sorgen oder so.
Du musst jetzt nicht einen Attest anlegen, zeigen das so, aber das,
was du bekommst, sind halt nicht tausende Euro, sondern vielleicht irgendwie hundert,
Also der Schadensersatz, der dir zugesprochen wird, ist verhältnismäßig gering.
Die Frage ist ja, wie groß ist mein Aufwand? Wo muss ich jetzt klicken?
Das ist, das wirst du halt sehen.
Also da denke ich, wird sich jetzt die Anwaltschaft neu formieren und zusehen,
wie man daraus ein einfaches Geschäftsmodell macht.
Also zum Beispiel bei diesen Flugerstattungen ist das ja auch so.
Das kannst du, da kriegst du irgendwie so und so viel 100 Euro,
das ist ein Fixbetrag, aber die nerven dich zu Tode und deswegen hat sich ja
dieses Geschäftsmodell herausgebildet, dass du diese Ansprüche einfach abtrittst.
Dann wirfst du da einfach, die sagen einmal, gib uns alles, wir kümmern uns,
wir nerven die so lange, bis wir Geld haben, aber dann kriegst du halt auch
nur, was weiß ich, 60 Prozent davon und die anderen 40 sind von uns und das
ist für viele halt ein fairer Deal.
Bevor ich mich jetzt irgendwie sechsmal hin und her mit der Lufthansa streite,
nehme ich lieber einen Anbieter,
der mir den Anspruch abkauft zu einem noch nachteiliger für mich oder einer,
der sagt, er nimmt mir nur dann das Geld weg, wenn es auch Erfolg gibt,
aber dann eben quasi auch nachteilig für mich.
Es könnte also sein, dass sich jetzt die Anwälte, die sowas automatisiert machen,
eher darauf konzentrieren, das mit sehr geringem Aufwand für sich selber und
mit sehr geringem Aufwand für die Betroffenen zu machen.
Es gibt auf jeden Fall bei Stiftung Warentest Musterbriefe, wo man sich noch anmelden kann.
Das sollte man aber dann auch dieses Jahr noch tun, weil sich da,
glaube ich, demnächst auch schon so das eine oder andere verjährt.
Und ja, dann kann man halt hier irgendwie so einen Musterbrief hinschicken und
sagen, ich will auch nochmal 100 Euro haben.
Aber es ist mir zu viel Aufwand. Bin zu faul für.
Vielleicht war das auch gar nicht meine Nummer. Wer weiß.
Doch, das ist deine Nummer. Ich habe ja...
Pst, pst.
Was du hier immer alles verrätst. Meine Telefonnummer, meine Passwörter. Schlimm.
23 Pro Nummer 42. Das war ein schöner Sendungstitel.
Ich bin doch hier das eigentliche Opfer.
Im DAL-Paket musst du noch eine Zollgebühr für zahlen. Klicke bitte hier.
Und dann wollte ich noch wissen, mit deinen Microsoft-Updates und dann hattest
du noch einen schweren Verkehrsunfall.
Oh, wirklich? Ja. Gut, dass du mich drauf hinweist. Das hätte ich jetzt nicht bemerkt.
Gut, damit sind wir, glaube ich, thematisch schon weitgehend durch.
Jetzt gibt es noch ein paar Bettelbriefe.
Bettelbriefe.
Also, none of your business.
Ich habe ein Jobangebot. Die suchen eine zusätzliche PR-Mitarbeiterin mit Fokus Grafik und Video.
Bitte deutschsprachig.
Zur Erinnerung, das sind die, die immer Facebook triezen.
Ja.
Nicht nur, aber auch.
Die, die mal Facebook tritzen.
Vor allem.
Und die planen hier 20 bis 40 Stunden in ihrem Büro in Wien.
So ein Viertel Homeoffice kann
man gut machen. Sie unterstützen sogar die Übersiedlung aus dem Ausland.
Also Migration in dem Fall.
Details gibt es.
Oder auch Remigration. Wer Lust hat, nach Österreich zu remigrieren,
das ist auch hier die Gelegenheit von Neub nach Wien.
Wenn sie sowieso demnächst rausgeschmissen werden, dann können sie auch gleich
da anfangen zu arbeiten.
Ja, unter Neub.eu Jobs ist dieses Posting und ja, Wien.
Schöne Stadt, guck mal hier, da ist auch nette Leute abgebildet.
PR-Manager, Data Protection Lawyer, Full-Stack-Developer.
Die sind da, die expandieren. In allem, was demnächst von der KI abgelöst wird.
Das ist alles nur so KI-Jobs.
Also wer da noch schnell in Lohn und Brot will, guck mal hier, PR-Manager, zack, KI.
Data-Protection-Lawyer, zack, KI. Full-Stack-Developer, zack, KI.
Legal-Trainee, also wer da noch mal kurz ein paar Monate in die Rentenkasse
einzahlen will, bis wir alle arbeitslos sind, kann das jetzt bei Neub tun.
Ich wollte jetzt nur den Leuten noch ein bisschen mehr Angst machen,
den Freelancern, dass sie noch schnell vielleicht doch noch einen Job annehmen.
Nein, das ist natürlich falsch. Die KI wird uns den Job nicht wegnehmen.
Das Kapital wird uns einfach nicht mehr beschäftigen.
So, und dann ist bald Weihnachten.
Ja.
Heute schon am Morgen denken.
Heute schon am Morgen denken, kauft uns Geschenke.
Kauft unser Geschenke. Ihr könnt ja Das stimmt.
Das könnt ihr machen.
Das könnt ihr machen. Man kann Geschenke kaufen. Bei uns kann man Geschenke
kaufen. Jeder andere verschenkt die.
Bei uns muss man dafür bezahlen. Wir machen...
Wir verkaufen die. Wir sagen, wenn Goldrausch ist, Geld verdienen die,
die die Schippen herstellen und wir stellen Geschenke her. Wir verkaufen Geschenke.
Es ist Weihnachten, da kannst du doch jetzt nicht mit Humor kommen.
Da muss man irgendwie einen betroffenen Tonfall aufsetzen und irgendwie mit
hoher Bedürftigkeit argumentieren.
Ja, wir brauchen Geld, damit wir Geschenke kaufen können.
Für uns.
Und zwar brauchen wir das Geld schnell und viel, weil bald der Cyber Monday
ist und dann können wir mehr kaufen.
Cybermandy kommt jetzt auch. Achso, das war ja auch kurz.
Ist irgendein Tag noch nicht von
irgendeiner kapitalistischen Ausbeutung geprägt? Was noch über Dienstag?
Gibt es auch einen Cyber Tuesday?
Also wir müssen auf jeden Fall, also jetzt müsste also für Dienstag reicht mein
Geld auf jeden Fall nicht mehr. Cyber Tuesday?
Der Logbuch Dienstag.
Was ist denn? Cyber Tuesday gibt es auch. Bei Substack. Das ist ein Blog von
irgendeinem. Und ein Podcast.
Ach Gott. Ja, hier gibt es überhaupt gar keinen Cyber.
Aber es sei jetzt einfach nochmal dezent, einmal im Jahr dürfen wir das ja auch mal betonen.
Also hier alle Produktionen aus der Meta-Ebene, gibt es alles kostenlos, vollständig.
Kein irgendwie Hidden Content, kein irgendwie Kapitelmarken nur für Aufpreis,
immer alles kompletto, ohne Bullshit.
Ja, also stets bemüht. Stets bemüht.
Ja, also Bullshit und werbefrei ist auf jeden Fall immer das Versprechen gewesen,
weil es kommt auf den Content an.
Genau, das werbefrei finde ich das viel entscheidendere. Wir verkaufen eure
Aufmerksamkeit nicht ans Kapital.
Genau, das machen wir nicht. Da bin ich erstens viel zu faul zu und zweitens
mag ich das nicht. Ja, sind wir falsch.
Weil so ist es uns auch selbst recht.
Nichtsdestotrotz hat das Ganze natürlich einen bestimmten Aufwand.
Gereit muss erworben werden. Dienste müssen regelmäßig bezahlt werden.
Da kommt auch ganz schön was zusammen.
Also ich muss das demnächst mal ein bisschen tabulieren. Also was allein so an so Payment,
Paywall-Zahlungen für News-Quellen,
da kommt schon das eine oder andere zusammen und meine wohl gewählten teuren
Domains kosten auch ganz schön was.
Also, ihr wisst schon, so eine Operation hat Kosten und Meta-Ebene läuft einfach
immer weiter, ist immer da für euch, so wie das Logbuch.
Und ihr sorgt dafür, dass das auch so bleibt.
Genau, und das könnt ihr tun, indem ihr erstens einen Podcast weiterempfehlt,
damit wir mehr Reichweite haben, die wir dann nicht vermarkten. mag.
Und das ist glaube ich inzwischen doppelt wichtig, weil wir ja auch nicht auf
Spotify und Audible und den ganzen Plattformen sind, die dann nämlich Werbung einspielen würden,
oder uns irgendwelche Vorgaben machen, dass wir sie nicht kritisieren dürfen.
Oder muss sie als nächstes einfallen lassen.
Das heißt, das machen wir auch nicht. Und das ist durchaus ein spürbarer Effekt,
was die Hörerinnen und Hörer angeht.
Was man so hört von anderen Podcasts, wie viel Prozent ihrer Hörerinnen und
Hörer, die über Spotify haben, das haben wir nicht.
Und deswegen freuen wir uns auch, wenn ihr den Podcast weiterempfehlt.
Und damit Leute in die schöne, freie, dezentrale Welt des Podcastgenusses bringt, die wir pflegen.
Über Feeds mit einem Abspielgerät deiner Wahl, nicht auf der Plattform deiner Wahl.
Übrigens, Tim, weißt du, was mir auch aufgefallen ist?
Was ist mir aufgefallen?
Bei anderen Podcasts.
Also, ich hatte ja, also ich benutze ja aus Gründen der Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
Vermeidung, in vielen weiten Teilen ein VPN.
Und dieses VPN mündet natürlich in einem anderen Land, wo die Bits freier sind.
Und das ist ein Land, dessen Sprache ich nicht spreche. Das heißt,
wann immer irgendwelche Werbung reingeschnitten wird, wird mein Gehirn damit
nicht vergiftet, sondern es ist eher so ein bisschen Duolingo,
dass ich dann so mir anhören kann,
wie in anderen Ländern Produkte beworben werden, die mich nicht interessieren.
Jetzt habe ich das mal irgendwie eine Zeit lang abgeschaltet und jetzt kriege
ich da tatsächlich deutsche Werbung, die sich nicht nur auf Deutschland bezieht,
sondern sogar auf Berlin.
Irgendwas mit Single-Frauen in meiner Nähe.
Wirklich?
Nein, aber tatsächlich irgendwie Berlin-bezogene Werbung.
Das habt ihr davon, dass ihr den, dass ihr die schöne Podcast-Welt erstens an
Spotify gegeben habt und zweitens jetzt an die Werbemafia.
Weil jetzt, das war der andere Teil, der in der Podcast-Welt lange Zeit noch
nicht existierte, dieses Ganze targeted.
Also es gab nicht diese, du surfst durch Internet.
Egal welche Webseite du besuchst, kriegst immer das gleiche Paar Schuhe angeboten,
weil in jeder Webseite eh das gleiche Werbenetzwerk eingebunden ist,
was sämtliches Verhalten von dir über das Netz trackt.
Und die hatten die ganze Zeit noch keinen Zugriff auf Podcasts,
weil das eine große Mediendatei war, die da lag, die unverändert war.
Und dann kam irgendwann das Interesse, naja, das wäre ja schon sehr gut,
wenn man da live Werbung reinschneiden könnte, je nachdem, woher der Zugriff kommt.
Und dann wäre es natürlich sehr gut, wenn man seinen Podcast in die Vermarktung
gibt und am Ende gar nicht mehr einen Vermarktungsvertrag zwischen meinem Podcast
und der Werbekundin zustande kommt,
sondern ich quasi meine Hörerinnen und Hörer einer Vermarktungsplattform gebe,
die dann Targeted Advertising macht und sagt zum Beispiel, ach so,
du willst an Podcast-Hörer in Berlin werben, wunderbar, dann schneiden wir das
bei den Podcasts, wo wir das können, an der Stelle rein.
Und das passiert jetzt schon. Und das finde ich auch nicht erfreulich.
Dafür haben wir das eigentlich sehr lange schön stabil gehalten.
So über viele Jahrzehnte, bis es dann irgendwann...
Bis man ihr auf einmal gemerkt hat, hey, schau mal da, das haben wir noch nicht
mit Werbung verseucht und das genießen Leute.
Es ist ja immer so eine schleichende Übernahme. Ich meine, es fing halt irgendwie
an, so mit diesen, wie heißt das so schön, Native Advertisements,
also man lässt dann quasi die Werbung vorlesen.
Das ist eigentlich auch bei populären Podcasts besonders einträglich.
War eine Weile lang vielleicht auch bei kleineren Podcasts so ein Ding,
aber jetzt in zunehmendem Maße, wenn so eine Werbemaschine dann erstmal angelaufen
ist, dann geht es irgendwann nur noch um Automatisierung und Datenauswertung.
Um genau diese automatische Einspielung zu machen, nach was für Triggerworte
sind denn jetzt hier irgendwie relevant und Reichweite,
Zielgruppenanalyse, wenn man auf einmal wissen, wie alt sind denn die Leute,
deswegen werden diese Plattformen bevorzugt, weil ihr dort natürlich alle ihr
Geburtsdatum eingeben und ihr Genderabdruck hinterlassen und dann kann man halt
genau sehen, wer hört denn jetzt hier wie viel etc.
Und irgendwann werden natürlich dann auch die Preise und die Anteile für die
Podcasts, die sozusagen die Werbung dann letzten Endes,
also die ihrer Publikum der Werbung zur Verfügung stellen,
um dann Botschaften anderer Leute zuzustellen über das eigene Netzwerk,
was man sich mit dem Podcast geschaffen hat.
Und deren Anteil daran wird dann auch immer geringer.
Also es gab vor ein paar Jahren da halt so ein Search, dann haben das viele
gemacht und mittlerweile bricht dieser Markt dann halt auch wieder ein.
Und man kann eigentlich nur noch daran teilnehmen, indem man dann eben auch
dem maximalen Ausverkauf zustimmt.
Während eben richtig profitieren dann eben wieder nur diejenigen mit diesen
Mega-Reichweiten, Also die
dann irgendwie sechs- und siebenstellig in den Hörerzahlen unterwegs sind,
die können natürlich dann immer für sich die besten Bedingungen raushandeln
und der Rest hat dann halt irgendwie zu sehen, wo er bleibt.
Gut, das ist so ein bisschen der Lauf der Dinge, das ist allerdings so ein Lauf,
an dem ich niemals Interesse hatte teilzunehmen und auch wenn man im Vorfeld
nicht unbedingt immer genau sehen konnte,
wohin die Reise mit all dem so geht, war mir irgendwie immer schon klar,
wohin auch die Reise mit euch immer geht ist, ich will auf gar keinen Fall mitreisen,
weil das kann alles nur furchtbar enden und ja.
Insofern sind wir jetzt hier noch übrig und bleiben auf unserer Insel stolz
mit durchgedrückten Rücken und setzen auf euren Support.
Einzige Finanzierungsmöglichkeit, die wir haben.
Wer auch auf euren Support setzt, ist Epicenter Works.
Wir hatten ja schon mal darauf hingewiesen. Das ist die NGO von Thomas Lohninger,
der ja auch sehr regelmäßig hier im Logbuch mitwirkt, von euch allen sehr geschätzt
wird, immer freundliche Kommentare bekommt.
Und der, die haben, wo ist denn jetzt hier?
Kleines Finanzloch von aktuell noch 40.000 Euro und da freuen wir uns,
empfehlen wir euch die Fördermitgliedschaft.
Die gibt es in Gold, Silber und Basik.
Da kann man irgendwie monatlich spenden. Monatliche Spenden sind die besten Spenden,
weil sie wiederkehrend sind und irgendwann vergessen werden und dann ein kalkulierbares
Einkommen ermöglichen für die Organisation,
und damit auch eine langfristige Unabhängigkeit.
Deswegen raten wir zur Unterstützung von Epicenter Works.
Und zu mehr raten wir jetzt nicht, weil reicht ja so. Genug gebettelt.
Genug.
Es ist ja nicht, dass wir hier Battlestar Galactica aufmachen.
Uiuiui Uiuiui, das war auch wieder gleich wieder Punktabzug Leute,
vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und wir hören uns bald wieder und auf die eine oder
andere Art und Weise oder?
Das auf jeden Fall, wir sehen uns auch beim Kongress.
Und dann sehen wir weiter.
Und dann.
Sehen wir weiter.
Dann gucken wir mal, also solange es noch netzpolitische Nachrichten gibt,
machen wir jetzt hier weiter.
Liefern wir die auch noch nach.
Alles klar, bis bald. Tschüss, tschüss.
Ciao, ciao.